they're more than 275,000 infections
worldwide and more than 11,000 deaths
Italy crossed a grim milestone this week
surpassing China as the global epicenter
of the pandemic but there is some
encouraging news about the caseload Ian
Lee is in London good morning Europe
continues to struggle to contain the
coronavirus more countries are now
ordering non-essential businesses to
close and when you think it can't get
any worse for Italy it does patients on
life support in an Italian hospital so
too is the country's medical system in
the last day six hundred and twenty
seven people have died making it not
only Italy's deadliest day but the
deadliest day worldwide since the
outbreak began advice from Europe's
epicenter flatten the curve if he was
going down enough you can take care of
people otherwise any any system will be
overwhelmed by the mass of sick people
in one or two days there's no
glad-handing for the Duke and Duchess of
Cambridge
the royal couple visited an emergency
dispatch center in London the government
here recently asked 65,000 retired
doctors and nurses to report for duty at
cafes pubs and restaurants it's last
call as they've been ordered to close I
understand the pubs to being closed
six months is a bit of a long time to
not go to a pub for us English person
especially that we all live for the pub
so I believe and I think if the pubs in
the world is shutting down with empty
streets from Baghdad to Bogota and
London to Lisbon Japan is feeling
growing pressure to cancel this summer's
Olympic Games as athletes practicing
social distancing trained from home but
in China life begins to return to normal
ruthless tactics to stop the pandemic
seemed to have worked
Wuhan the virus's epicenter reported no
new cases for the third straight day the
communist government is now shifting to
deliver aid to hard-hit countries a move
to gloss over its initial failure to
contain a local virus now on a global
scale it's been two weeks since the
first confirmed coronavirus death in the
UK since then the death toll has risen
faster than Italy over the same period
leading some to fear the Italians could
be giving us a glimpse of the future
here Dayna Ian Lee in London Thank You
Ian